لم يمضي يومنا على تحذير يامن عام الوكاله
الدوريه للطاقه الذريه رفيال جروستي من ان
القتال المتزايد في محيطي منشاه زابوريجيا
يجعل تامينها مهمه صعبه حتى استفاق غروسيا
على خبر تفجير سد نوفا الذي يؤمنوا مياه
التبريد للمنشاه
gs الذي سارع لاحاطه مجلس المحافظين
بطبيعات ذلك على المنشاه النوويه قال ان
مياه التبريد من خزان السد ستتوقف بعد
ايام ولكنه تحدث عن بدائل تؤمنها بوركو
تبريد ومجاوره للمنشاه النوويه تكفي لبضعه
اشهر
من الضروري ان تظل بروكو التبريد سليمه
يجب الا يحصل اي شيء يعرض سلامتها للخطر
لذا ادعو جميع الاطراف الى ضمان عدم
القيام بشيء لتقويض سلامتها العواقب يمكن
ان تكون خطيره
السفير الروسي من حق العليانوب الذي اراد
الاحتفال بيوم اللغه الروسيه في مقر الامم
المتحده في فيينا وجد نفسه مضطرا للتحدث
بالانجليزيه وليس بالروسيه كما اراد للرد
على دعوه جروستي جميع الاطراف تامين برك
التبريد
لا يحتاج الامر قول ان كل الجهود ستبذل
لتامين الامن النووي والقول ان روسيا تعرض
منشاتها النوويه للخطر هو امر سخيف نحن
اسسنا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه كنا
من الدول المؤسسه وبالطبع دائما نتعاون مع
الوكاله ونتوقع ان تتعاون الوكاله معنا
وفيما تراقب الوكاله تاثير تفجير السد على
محطه زابوريا دقيقه بدقيقه كما قال جروستي
تحشد اوكرانيا هنا ايضا داخل مجلس
المحافظين لردود دوليه تدين روسيا التي
تتهمها بتدمير السد فور انتهاء اعمال مجلس
المحافظين هنا نهايه هذا الاسبوع سيتوجه
فورا الى منشاه زابوريجيا في زياره كان
مخططا لها مسبقا ولكنها الان باتت اساسيه
كما قال في محاوله لاحتوائ اي تصعيد محتمل
يخشى ان يتسبب بكارثه النوويه را غده
بهنام العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات